Before we can answer the question of what the earth's circumference is,
we need to start thinking about what the shape of the earth is.
Now, our earth is a sphere.
When we draw this sphere we often include lines of latitude,
which go from east to west, and the center line of latitude, which occurs at 0 degrees.
We call it the equator.
We also draw lines on longitude, which go from north to south
and are all of equal length.
Now, it's a common misconception that the ancient Greeks thought the earth was flat,
but this was simply not the case.
The ancient Greeks knew the earth was spherical,
or at least they had good reason to believe it was.
Let's start thinking about geometry by cataloging
some of the evidence the Greeks had available to them
and deciding which pointed towards a spherical earth.
First, the Greeks knew that the earth casts a circular shadow on the moon
during a lunar eclipse.
A lunar eclipse occurs when the earth gets between the sun and the moon,
and the earth casts a shadow on the moon.
The Greeks also knew that when traveling at sea,
you can see farther--a greater distance--from the top of the mast than from the deck of the ship.
That's why when you look at old ships, you often see a crow's nest high up on the mast
where a spotter could look for land.
Third, the Greeks knew that the moon and the sun appeared as disks in the sky.
Finally, the Greeks also knew that the sun appears lower in the sky as you travel north.
Now, this only applies for someone living in the Northern Hemisphere,
but that's where the Greeks lived.
Now, if we want to distinguish between a spherical earth and a disk-shaped earth,
we have to use our evidence.
Now, this is the evidence that was available to the Greeks,
so I want you to think through each of these four points and decide for each one
whether it best supports the idea that the earth is a sphere,
that the earth is a disk, or maybe it supports both or neither of these.
Go ahead and select one button for each of these four points.
Now, this is a tricky quiz, and some of these you could actually debate the answer.
So, don't worry if you don't get it right on the first try.